[Música]
economía aquí en directo América edición
nocturna me acompañan el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge buenas noches ya lo
mencionamos en el bloque de noticias y
ese principio de acuerdo para
desbloquear las exportaciones de
cereales y de granos desde los puertos
ucranianos Santiago hay que recordar sin
duda que Rusia y Ucrania son actores
claves en el comercio mundial de granos
y esta guerra sin duda está poniendo en
riesgo de hambruna a varias regiones del
mundo se acordaron cuestiones como el
establecimiento de un centro de
coordinación en Estambul los controles
conjuntos en los puntos de salida y
destino de los puertos y la garantía de
la seguridad de la navegación en las
rutas de traslado por ejemplo Ucrania
pidió garantías de seguridad frente a
los ataques rusos se accede a eliminar
las minas marinas que colocó para
proteger sus puertos donde Ahora hay más
de 20 millones de toneladas de cereales
y semillas de girasol que no pueden
salir a los mercados Internacionales La
escasez mundial de esos productos está
agravada además por de fertilizantes
rusos que se dejaron de exportar tras
esta invasión en la mediación estuvo
Naciones Unidas y Turquía quienes buscan
aliviar el fuerte incremento de los
precios en los mercados de alimentos
sobre todo para países pobres de África
y medio oriente Jorge pasemos ahora a
hablar de la economía de Estados Unidos
la inflación en junio alcanzó el máximo
en cuatro décadas en ese país
principalmente por el aumento en los
precios de los combustibles que lo que
está pasando el dato Fue bastante brutal
9,1% aumentaron los precios en un año en
Estados Unidos el mayor salto interanual
desde 1981 este aumento fue impulsado
por el precio de la energía en un año
los precios de la energía aumentaron
allí casi un 42% mientras que los de la
gasolina aumentaron 61% en el último año
pero Cómo inició este repunte de los
precios hay que recordar que tras los
cierres de la pandemia la economía
protagonizó una recuperación inesperada
en 2021 alimentada sobre todo por
grandes y inyecciones de duda
gubernamental la vacunas también
animaron a los consumidores a volver a
los restaurantes a los bares a las
tiendas a los aeropuertos y a lugares de
ocio pero las empresas no pudieron con
esa gran demanda los puertos y los
almacenes de carga no podían manejar el
tráfico y fue cuando comenzamos a ver a
todo estos barcos varados en los
principales puertos del mundo el aumento
al aumentar esta demanda Y al disminuir
los suministro Los costos sin duda se
dispararon la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos anunció grandes subidas de tipos
de interés para tratar de frenar la
inflación pero la respuesta es riesgosa
podría desacelerar la economía lo
suficiente para frenar la inflación pero
sin debilitar tanto como para provocar
una recesión y esa es la gran incógnita
en estos momentos que mantiene al el
dólar al alza y también los precios
difícil ese balance para para mantener
la economía a flote también lo estamos
viendo en Canadá país que también ya
anunció aumentos en las tasas de interés
también la inflación está haciendo de
las suyas allí el Banco Central Cana sin
duda dio las sorpresas subió los tipos
de interés en 100 puntos básicos Canadá
sorprendió a los mercados y se convierte
en el primer país del g7 que realiza una
subida tan agresiva en este ciclo
económico dijeron que no será el último
o la última subida del Banco Central
argumentó esta subida por el exceso de
demanda la elevada inflación y las
crecientes expectativas de los
consumidores de un aumento persistente
de los precios que motivaron esta subida
del movimiento de los 100 puntos básicos
unido a la advertencia de que habría más
subidas podría asustar a los mercados
según los economistas la tasa de
inflación de Canadá alcanzó el 7,7%
anual en mayo cerca de un máximo de 40
años pasemos ahora a hablar de Panamá
allí También el aumento de los precios
ha llevado a la gente a protestar y a
manifestarse en las calles en las
últimas dos semanas cómo está el
panorama allí bueno los panameños
también reclaman por la corrupción
gubernamental las protestas continúan
pese al anuncio de recortes de los
precios de los combustibles y algunos
productos alimenticios anuncia por el
gobierno los sindicatos afirman que las
protestas van a seguir hasta que se
produzca una reducción general de los
precios y la gasolina baje a menos de
tres dólares por galón el gobierno en el
sector empresarial temen ahora que el
país pueda sufrir Una caída de la
actividad económica o impactos en la
industria del turismo debido a estas
manifestaciones y bloqueo escuchamos que
decían ahí los sindicatos
porque los problemas no solamente de un
sector El problema este es todos los
panameños que estamos sufriendo el día
de hoy apoyamos la lucha y Seguiremos
luchando Hasta que el gobierno nos
atienda y resolver los problemas de
nuestra comarcas
ponemos punto final a la economía Jorge
muchas gracias por este reporte a
continuación en directo América el
debate
[Música]